this whole time that we were in training
camp and guys were you know doing
conditioning drills the ladder drills no
helmets on nobody's getting injured
nobody's getting injured but what we had
looming was padded practices and we knew
what was going to happen because it
happens every damn year
every time these guys show up claiming
they're in the best in shapeness of
their life as you would say
and then they start hitting each other
and as you said yesterday the most
nervous you'd ever been rookie year
padded practice first day with john
gruden warren sapp all the other tampa
bay buccaneers great defensive players
from back in that day guys get injured
and it was amazing to see the list of
guys who got injured yesterday guys who
are lost for the season guys who are out
indefinitely and with only 80 guys in
camp it puts stress on the remaining
guys to get all the reps in to get all
the work done and you may see some
conscious decisions by coaches to pull
back what a balance it is this year
chris yes it is on one hand you got to
get guys ready with no pre-season on the
other hand
you got to make sure your guys are
healthy enough to go when the regular
season starts no well you know this is
something we talked about a lot before
like our july break right where you know
and even early on when we came back in
late july
this is a this was a concern for me in a
year like this without the off-season
program that
you know get used to this i i think
injuries will be a theme of the year i
mean that would be something if you made
me you know be nostradamus or you know
my crystal ball in the weird year of
2020 i would say injuries are going to
have you know a lot to say about what
happens in this football season first
off guys are just getting in shape wait
wait yeah wait i know i went dr doom you
stuck the landing with nostradamus thank
you almost okay good okay i will almost
no okay when it came out i was like i
don't know
i wasn't sure but i just landed with it
the landing that's a little wobbly like
the right foot comes up a little bit but
then you put it back down that i'll give
you that one well now now i've gotten to
the i've gotten to the point now where i
mean you guys dissect my words and
everything that i'm like i'm that
quarterback that's thrown three or four
interceptions in a game now now every
time i'm dropping back to pass i'm like
whoa oh i'm afraid okay i'm not that all
right no no no no you're that
quarterback that's trying to spit out
the play call and can't i can't remember
who it is you're funny you are funny
yeah you're doing lots of jazz i can't
remember who it is i can't recall uh i
just can't recall uh but yes mike
that's something i'm worried about no no
doubt about that i mean you know again
like we just talked about you know
there's guys here that yeah they were at
home they were working out but they
weren't going through like you know
like rigorous training like you you're
supposed to be in may april june you
know as a football player you're
starting to lift heavier weights all
those things hey science has proven that
you know it is six weeks before muscles
and tendons truly strengthen and we're
going through a sped up process here
this year so it's gonna lead to injuries
and you know
it's gonna lead to an interesting few
weeks of football too as you know
players and teams get their feet
underneath them a little bit
some of the things jj watts said back
when they were in the process of trying
to figure out what training camp would
look like his concern was his rookie
year 2011 after the lockout 25 increase
in injuries and back then guys were able
to work out like they normally would
away from the team facility right this
year you can't you can't go to the gym
right you're stuck with whatever you
happen to have available to you some
guys like jj watt who's made plenty of
money has a great setup in his house
other guys just getting started they
don't have that they've been working out
at their college facility for the past
four or five years or three years as the
case may be and now they're just kind of
out in the wilderness they thought they
would go to their new team headquarters
and work out there and that didn't
happen so you're going to see guys
across the spectrum and we're going to
see guys get injured and it's just part
of the reality of trying to hold
everything together until we get to
september 10 for the first regular
season game and then to september 13th
for the first full sunday and then
injuries are going to happen then yeah
once teams are out there on the field
playing each other
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports